c'est une première dans les yvelines le
public et le privé investisse ensemble
dans un établissement pour personnes
âgées
le centre hospitalier de versailles la
clinique médicale de la porte verte et
la ville de versailles se sont réunis au
sein d'une société coopérative d'intérêt
collectif à laquelle s'ajoute une
structure solidaire entreprendre pour
humaniser la dépendance on as de brasles
moins de 2000 actionnaires qui conclut
aujourd'hui en fait à travers une
épargne qui n'a pas encore une fois
qu'il n'a pas une vocation en fait sont
eux des dividendes a bien évidemment
mais en fait les gens qui investissent
ils entendent effectivement un résultat
mais ce cas résultat selon ce projet
nécessite 20 millions d'euros
d'investissement assuré en majorité par
un prêt locatif social pour compléter le
budget une originalité les versailles et
ont la possibilité d'investir en
souscrivant des parts sociales à hauteur
de 20 euros
le chantier est en fait la rénovation de
l'établissement lépine providence
abandonné pour malfaçons et qui devait
accueillir 200 résidents un nombre qui
avait fait bondir la mairie de
versailles
ça nous a paru monstrueux c'était
énorme maison de la vulnérabilité et
c'était contraire à ce que la population
nous renvoyait comme demande et c'est de
là qu'on s'est dit va comment
pouvons-nous répondre à cette obligation
de projet architectural mal fini qui a
besoin d'être repris et de répondre aux
besoins de la population
la structure proposera 112 places dont
quatre places d'hébergement temporaire
mais aussi 12 places d'accueil de jour
et 160 places de services soit
infirmiers à domicile dont 10
spécialisée alzheimer
l'ouverture de l'établissement lépine
providence est prévue début 2016